hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and
right here in front of me i have both
the ipad mini 6 and the ipad mini 5 and
the question that i'm going to answer in
this video is if it's worth actually
upgrading whether you have the mini 5 or
an older ipad mini because this is
actually the first full redesign that
we're getting for the ipad mini so to do
that i'm going to be comparing basically
everything between both of these ipads
we're talking the displays the designs
how the touch id system works the
performance basically everything
including the new apple pencil as well
as the new camera system so without
further ado let's go ahead and
take off this plastic wrap which the new
iphones don't have but i guess the ipads
still do get that out of the way
all right
there we have it wow look at that that
is beautiful guys all right now when
they say this is a mini ipad air it
basically is it's almost identical the
only thing i think it's missing is the
smart connector on the back which the
mini does not get because it is too many
so before i turn this on i want to guide
you guys through some of the differences
on the back of course we have the much
larger camera right here and the
microphone has been moved from the top
center over here right under the camera
and you also get that flash now one of
the major design differences i do want
to point out is that on the ipad mini 6
you do get the second gen apple pencil
wireless charger right here so you can
see just pops on it charges it connects
it and it does take almost the full side
of the ipad mini 6. now this definitely
tops the old method of charging the
pencil like you used to have to plug it
in it's sticking out it's annoying i'm
so glad that's gone now now because the
apple pencil does take up the full side
the volume buttons that used to be on
the side of the ipad mini now moved to
the top actually right over here right
next to the speaker grills and the cool
thing about this is that when you have
it in this orientation they actually
switch when you flip it so at this point
this is going to be the top if you
switch it the other way it flips in
software automatically which is really
really clever by apple now one of the
most important changes is that apple
finally gave the mini the usb type c
port and got rid of lightning this is
going to be extremely important because
usb type-c takes a lot more power and it
allows you to connect to more devices
whereas lightning is very very limited
and on top of that you can see that we
have speaker grills on the bottom but on
the new mini 6 you actually get a set on
the top now i know this next detail is
going to annoy some of you guys out
there but the ipad mini 6 no longer gets
a headphone jack which sucks but really
for us it's not that big of a deal now
before i show you guys the major changes
to touch id and everything else i do
want to mention that along with the new
redesign of the ipad mini 6 apple
actually did pack in extra magnets
throughout the internals just like on
the ipad pro and the ipad air so now the
new smartfolio actually connects on both
the back side and the front side using
just those internal magnets whereas on
the ipad mini 5 it actually connected to
the side and only covered the front so
you're getting a lot of protection and
this actually looks really nice and
clean because just how slim this folio
is like this is awesome now flipping
over to the front side let's go ahead
and just
boot up this ipad mini for the first
time but i do want to mention the design
differences
finally this old design with the white
bezels the home button is gone we now
have the new modern version with the
rounded corners on the display and those
even uniform bezels which obviously
looks much much better now along with
all those huge changes the other major
difference is touch id is now built into
the power button so i'm going to show
you guys the process right here
and as you can see i'm just
touching the power button just like that
and it is registering my
fingerprint now if you're wondering if
the new power button touch id is any
faster it is not because we actually
tested it with the ipad air and there
was no difference and even though this
is kind of cool to have that new touch
id i'd actually say that it's a little
bit more annoying because with the ipad
mini 5 you just go like this you tap the
button and it unlocks just like that but
with the mini you have to reach up and
hit it up there which can be a little
bit more annoying than just having it on
the face but either way it allows the
display to be obviously much more clean
like that now as far as the displays
because apple got rid of that home
button and the chins the actual ipad
mini 6 itself does get a little bit
shorter but it gets a little bit
skinnier on the sides because of those
slightly larger bezels compared to the
side on the ipad mini 6 but what that
gives you is basically the widest aspect
ratio in terms of watching videos which
is definitely a nice difference and in
terms of the hand i'd say that i
actually like the ipad mini 6 and how it
feels with those boxy edges compared to
the old chamfered edges which seem kind
of
slippery and of course the new mini 6
does have a larger 8.3 inch display
compared to 7.9 and because you're
getting rid of those extra distractions
like the home button and the chins this
is definitely a much more immersive
display even if it's not that much
bigger only five percent in terms of the
actual screen real estate and now with
all that display and design stuff out of
the way let's go ahead and jump into the
speaker comparison and see how much
better they are on the mini
we'll six started
[Music]
all right wow guys we've never really
complained about the ipad mini 5s
speakers they were always pretty good we
just complained that they were on one
side but now we have a huge improvement
on basically every level just having the
stereo speakers on both sides is
basically a 5x
times game changer in terms of speaker
quality however the old ipad mini 5
speakers they seem like they were tuned
for the high ends and you're missing out
on a lot of those mid band frequencies
like you're not really getting the
dynamic range between all the little
instruments and everything else but this
has like this richness to it where the
mids are clear you can hear them such a
huge difference with the new mini 6
compared to any old ipad mini
crazy with that out of the way let's
finally go and test the performance
starting out with geek match 5. you guys
can see that we're actually getting 4
gigs of ram on the mini 6 compared to
only three let's start off with the cpu
benchmark and while this test is running
i do want to mention that the mini 6 has
the brand new a15 bionic chip from the
iphone 13 it's not quite as fast because
it is down clocked to help save battery
life and the ipad mini 5 gets the old
a12 chip that is a pretty old chip it's
even older than the new ipad 9 with the
a13 so let's see how big of a difference
there is all right we have our scores
and this is an awesome difference going
from generation to generation for the
ipad mini we're going from 1114
single core to 1590
that is a 43
difference which is awesome now
interestingly the a15 single core is not
as high as on the iphone 13s so it's
definitely down clocked but if we go
over to the multi-core we're going from
2786 to 45.41
that is a 63
improvement which is awesome and this is
actually scoring close to the iphone 13
pro max so it seems like our theory on
whether the efficiency cores are much
faster is true they are much faster so
this is definitely a nice difference
let's go ahead and get into the compute
metal graphics test now while this is
running i do want to mention that apple
did not cheap out on the graphics on the
ipad mini 6 with the a15 because it does
get the new 5 core gpu so you're getting
the extra core on top of what you have
in the a12 and because of that we're not
just getting a 30 or 50 generational
improvement not even double we're
getting 2.63
times
faster graphics performance than the
ipad mini 5 which blows my mind so the
gaming performance on this is
insane and speaking of gaming let's see
how it fares in a real gaming benchmark
and 2-2 bench so let's go ahead and
start the antutu benchmark all right
guys just watching this playback the
ipad mini 6 literally perfectly smooth
and you're getting dropped frames
already on the ipad mini 5 even though
both displays are 60 hertz there is a
noticeable difference in terms of the
fps and smoothness we've got a score and
this is very interesting on two
different levels first of all the
performance difference is uh 42 higher
for the mini 6 which isn't as much as it
was before because this kind of factors
in everything and it's a real world test
but
this school right here 771 000 is very
impressive because the iphone 13 pro max
which is supposed to have faster chips
in terms of the cpu and gpu was only
slightly faster with 788 and the reason
for that is because the iphone suffers
from thermal throttling it overheats and
in these longer term benchmarks it has
to kind of slow down a bit but it looks
like the ipad mini doesn't have to
because it's larger and it dissipates
heat better this thing is impressive for
gaming photo editing video editing
basically anything that you can do on
this tablet it's gonna kill it and the
last thing i want to test in terms of
the performance is the ssd storage speed
so we have jazz disk test right here
let's go ahead and run it and with that
said we do actually get faster ssds in
the mini six you can see the write speed
is almost twice as fast 595 megabytes
per second compared to 266 the read
speeds are basically the same and in
terms of the iops you're getting 33
megabytes per second compared to 22 for
the read and 19 compared to 12 so that's
nice to see that even though they're 64
gigs we do get faster store speeds now
before i get into the conclusion and
answer the original question let's get
into those cameras because we do have
some differences obviously we have the
camera bump on the mini 6 and it is now
a 12 megapixel sensor with an f 1.8 lens
compared to f 2.4 so it's gonna let in
more light and it's gonna have more
resolution and if you're someone who
likes to scan documents the extra flash
on the mini 6 is definitely going to be
helpful and then flipping over to the
front side the mini 5 has a 7 megapixel
selfie camera and the new mini 6
actually has a 12 megapixel ultra wide
and what i mean by that is
boom you can go into ultrawide you can
do that linus meme face but there you go
you have that crazy ultra wide view
which looks really cool it's definitely
a unique perspective and this helps it
support the new center stage feature now
unfortunately because of the ultra wide
camera when you take a regular selfie
like this it's actually not as detailed
as the 7 megapixel sensor on the mini 5
and that's also why you can't shoot 4k
video with the selfie cam because it's
ultra wide so it crops in and gives you
1080p but it can go up to 60 fps which
the ipad mini 5 cannot do all right with
all of that said and compared let's
finally answer the original question
is it worth upgrading to the ipad mini 6
and the only thing i can say is
yes yes it is even at the higher price
of 500 which some people were
complaining about
this ipad basically fixes everything it
fixes the biggest issues that we had
with the ipad mini 5 and you're
basically getting the best of all worlds
you're getting killer speakers you're
getting the new design that's going to
be modern and future proof for years on
end you're getting excellent cameras
you're getting killer performance
performance that's only beaten by the m1
ipad pro which is already overkill for
everything you can't even use all that
power so with this thing for 500
that is actually a killer value for
everything that you're getting and if
you have even the ipad mini 5 or any of
the older ipad minis or even the other
ipads this thing's insane you've got to
upgrade to this so there you guys go as
you can tell i'm super excited and happy
about the ipad mini 6. apple did an
excellent job and even at 500
it's a killer value and definitely a
worthy upgrade so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and subscribe because we have a
ton more videos that we're working on
and definitely watch one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]